The first trailer for "Fast X" is
out and "Fast and Furious" fans sure
have some intense thoughts about Paul
Walker's brief but welcome appearance.
In true "Fast and Furious" manner, the first look
at "Fast X" confirms that the tenth entry in the
billion-dollar franchise will retroactively
make changes to fold in a new villain. "F9"
managed to convince fans that Dominic Torretto
had a secret brother this whole time in Jakob,
played by John Cena. Now, "Fast
X" confirms that Jason Momoa's
villain Dante is somehow connected to the
family's chaotic exploits in "Fast Five."
As the trailer kicks off, "Fast and Furious"
fans are treated to a family-hating monologue
from Momoa's character, which then cuts to
the events of "Fast Five." As Walker's Brian
and Diesel's Dom are stealing the giant safe
and parading it through the streets of Brazil,
fans see that Dante was there for every major
set piece during the fifth film's finale,
retroactively making him a pivotal character.
How exactly is Momoa's character connected to
"Fast Five"? Only time will tell. For
now, fans still can't get over how the
"Fast X" trailer managed to carefully tie in
moments from "Fast Five" that feature Walker.
"Furious 7" marked the last time Paul Walker
appeared in the franchise. The actor died in 2013
from a car crash, compelling the creative team
behind "Fast and Furious" to retool his character.
Since the seventh entry in the franchise, Walker's
Brian has appeared off-screen, retiring from the
family's action-packed shenanigans. The character
was last seen driving to the Toretto residence in
the final moments of "F9," closing off the
ninth entry in the ever-expanding franchise.
While seeing the character's car was certainly a
crowd-pleasing moment for "Fast and Furious" fans,
seeing Walker via flashbacks in the
latest trailer is making fans emotional.
One fan wrote, "Goosebumps watching
Paul Walker," in the YouTube comment
section of the trailer. Another
user echoed similar sentiments,
saying their "heart skipped a beat
seeing Paul Walker." It was a similar
situation on Twitter. A user expressed how
emotional it was to see Brian again, saying,
"The 'Fast X' trailer just made me so
emotional. Like, I know it's not the
first movie without Paul Walker, but
still [...] can't believe he's gone."
Another user expressed how the use of Brian in
the "Fast X" trailer made them miss
Walker even more. Yet another wrote,
"If Brian O'Connor returns in
'Fast X' I might actually cry."
While plot details on "Fast X" are slim,
"Fast and Furious" fans can't help but speculate
what the future entry has in store for Brian.
"Never accept death when suffering is owed."
Some fans think that Brian O'Connor will return
in the latest "Fast and Furious" movie. Following
Paul Walker's death in 2013, his brothers
Caleb and Cody were brought in as stand-ins
to film pivotal scenes for "Furious 7" that hadn't
been completed. With the help of visual effects,
Brian O'Connor was able to join the family one
last time. After seeing the "Fast X" trailer,
fans think Walker's brothers will
be brought back. A Redditor wrote,
"I strongly think Brian is going
to show back up via deep fake/CGI
over Paul Walker's brother(s) as body double."
Another fan agreed saying,
"I was okay with Brian playing babysitter
offscreen in 'F9' [ ... ] but with the
stakes this high it's harder to
buy him not getting involved."
Yet another user echoed other
fans' thoughts on Brian's return:
"Paul and his character were a big part of the
franchise and it'd be a shame to not see him be a
part of the finale and at least with his brothers
doing it, a part of Paul would be a part of it."
Other fans think that Brian will show up in a
different, more unique way. One Twitter user
speculated, "Brie Larson has to be playing Brian's
long lost sister, right?" Yet another suggested,
"Brie Larson's Tess is 100% going
to be revealed as Brian's sister
that no one knew he had because he never
mentioned her a single time before, right?"
Another user amusingly suggested
that "everyone with blonde hair
will be accused of being related
to Brian until proven otherwise."